- Depuis la mi-novembre, quatre
cas de streptocoques du groupe
enfants par la santé publique
de Montréal. Deux d'entre
se sont avérés mortels.
Dr CHRISTOS KARATZIOS, spécial.
infectiologie pédiatri
la population, je ne veux pas
paniquer le mond'e'e'est une
souche invasive, c'est une
souche qui produit des toxines.
- Si les strouououououououououot
des maladies bénignes comme
des infensnsns de la gorge,
elles peuvent dans de rares cas
causer une maladie plus grave,
deupupupupupupupupupupupupupupu,
les vomissements et les
diarrhées ne sont pas des
symptômes
- Entre 2017 et 2021, il nururus
par année dans la métropol
Comment donc expliquer cette
augmentation?
Une situation qui n'est pas
étrangère aux cas de grippe
qui ont explosé
- La grippe donne l'opportunité
à cette bactérie-là d'envahir
les tissus d
et des poumons.
IAN-PHILIP PAUL-HUS, pharmacien
- Ç
de minutes, on a le résultat.- s
de la province, il est même
possible de se faire déprererera
propagation de la bactérie.
- On peut prescrire des
antibiotiques, un traitement
conforme au dossiendndndndndndnt
antibiotique, en 24 h,
ça enlève la contagion.
- Devant cette augmentation,
cet infectararararararararararas
de prendre leurs précautions.
- L'autre chose qui est plus
importante que tout, tout,
tout
infection virale, évitez
e,e,e,e,e, évitez ça. Il y a
un moyen qu'on peut fairemememe.
- Un appel à la vaccination quÉe
- Ayant un nouveau-né, moi,ntntn
et mon conjoint est greffé f f n
fasse attention aux bactéries
qui rentrent à la maisababababau
ministre de la Santé dit suivre
de très près la situation avec
les autorités de santé publique.
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-Canada, M
Radio-C